(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- Hi guys!
Oh, thanks for hanging out with us.
Can I just share something
and be totally honest?
I am rocking the caffeine this morning
because I pulled an all-nighter
with my daughter, Frankie.
Yep.
I know, poor little sausage.
She was in total discomfort
and she couldn't go to the bathroom,
and Frankie, I so apologize
to your future self
for telling this story,
but I didn't know how to get around it.
I was like, I should just tell the truth.
So basically around 9:00
PM, the pain started,
and you cut to 9:30, 8:00
PM and we're in one bathroom
and I'm like, "Frankie,
honey, it's going to be okay.
Just don't push because
it's going to hurt more.
You just got to relax your
body, and I have got you."
Cut to 10:26, I administer Motrin.
11:08, she accuses me of not
giving her real medicine.
So I swear to her that the makers
of Motrin have got her back.
And at 1:02 AM, we're
now in the other bathroom
and I'm hovering over her, still calm,
once again telling her, "Don't push.
It's going to be okay."
And around 1:34, 43,
I'm sitting on the bathroom
floor this time, like,
"Don't push it.
Just stop pushing."
3:07 AM.
"You want to watch "Hocus Pocus"?"
And at 3:09, she says, "Mom, I'm cold."
So I wrap her in a bunch
of blankets on the couch,
and then at 3:17, she says,
"Mom, I need more room on the couch."
And I'm totally hanging off of it.
Okay, 3:28, "Mom, I'm still cold."
And I give her my one
last blanket that's tiny
and as I sit there freezing,
I look at her and I think,
"I wouldn't have it any other way."
(audience clapping)
And the good news is it
turns out this morning,
she's feeling great.
Fresh as a daisy.
Apparently no discomfort
whatsoever, so good news.
Virtual friends, who was
in the all-nighters club
with their kids?
Katie and Lucy!
Hi!
- Oh, yes.
Actually, hi, Drew!
- Oh, mothers and daughters, I love it.
How are you guys?
- Good, a big mommy hug to you.
We all feel your pain, but we
know sickness or no sickness,
being a mom, you never get any sleep,
so we all feel your pain this morning.
- Thank you so much,
and bless you to you and
your gorgeous daughter.
And it's true, we'll do
anything for our kids.
And sometimes we just
have to be honest about it
instead of coming out here
and pretending to be perfect all the time.
I'm like, "I haven't slept.
I feel nuts.
Let's do this."
You guys are rock stars, and
you do feel like a rock star
when you pull an all-nighter,
just in a totally different way.
And speaking of rock star moms,
Gabrielle Union is on the show today.
Oh, we love her!
And now, let's kick it
off with some Drew's News.
(brakes screeching)
(cat meowing)
(dramatic music)
Excuse me, sir!
Ma'am!
Guy!
Tell me your story!
Ma'am, I asked you a question.
This is Drew's News!
This is Drew's News.
It's Drew's News!
(audience cheering)
Every day, our team, we
come up with headlines
to find stories that simply made us happy,
and let's see what made the papers.
Okay, you know sometimes
you just read a story
and you're like, "Yes, I love humanity."
And this one did that for me.
It also made me hungry.
Okay, I saw this morning,
Travel + Leisure reports
that there's a new record
for world's largest chocolate fountain.
It's a 30-foot cascade of
melted chocolate falling
into a big old Lindor.
Oh yes, give it to me.
I love sweet, but I'm also
maybe thinking nacho cheese
might be better too?
I don't know.
Hey, virtual friends, sweet or savory?
Samantha, which one floats your boat?
- Me and the girls here, we choose.
- [Girls] Both,
chocolate-covered pretzels.
- I think pretzels and
chocolate and nacho cheese.
I would get a little
Tostitos Scoop and rock it.
Thanks, Samantha.
Okay, well, good work Lindt.
You made the world happy.
And if chocolate fountains
aren't your thing,
can I interest you in a wine backpack?
You heard me.
Fox News reports that
box wine maker Franzia
has just developed a backpack that doubles
as a wine dispenser.
Uh huh.
A crucial accessory for
any Merlot lover on the go.
#merlotonthego.
Franzia also announced
swimsuits, boxer shorts, socks,
and other accessories.
I mean, you guys, can you
imagine an entire outfit made out
of Franzia products?
It's like, "Who are you wearing?"
"It's Franzia by Franzia."
I feel like if you're rocking the Franzia
and draining that backpack,
they're going to have to come up
with a few more products
like Franzia electrolytes,
Franzia mattresses for the old pass out,
and maybe some morning
huevos rancheros by Franzia.
(audience applauding)
Okay, so moving on, this
next story really got me.
According to a new study
reported by People Magazine,
who we love, a dog's
heart rate increases 46%
whenever its owner says I love you.
I mean, can you even handle the sweetness?
It's like, I can't.
It's me and my girls, we have
two dogs, Douglas and Lucy.
That's them.
And it just makes me so happy to think
that it gets our dog's heart racing
when we say those three little words.
And Douglas and Lucy, if
you're watching, I love you.
I love you!
So take some time to tell
your good boy or good girl
that you love them too.
(upbeat music)